an Illinois couple charged with killing
their five-year-old son is due in court
this morning after the discovery of a
body
Andrew friend senior and Joann
Cunningham are each charged with
first-degree murder among other charges
memorial was held for a Jay friend last
night outside the family's home Nicky
batiste is following the investigation
Nicky good morning Anthony good morning
investigators found what they believed
to be AJ's body yesterday six days after
he was reported missing his cause of
death is unknown
AJ's parents had denied wrongdoing for
days
now investigators say they are trying to
determine their motive for AJ's murder
is with heavy heart that the Crystal
Lake had two police department reports
that we've located what we believe to be
the body of Andrew AJ friend since last
Thursday police had unsuccessfully
searched a wide area on foot using dogs
and drones but after removing several
items from the family home yesterday
including a shovel investigators said
they got their break when they
confronted the parents with cell phone
evidence both Joanne and Andrew senior
provided information that ultimately led
to the recovery what we believe is the
recovery of deceased subject AJ the
parents LED police about ten miles away
to Woodstock Illinois where AJ's body
was found wrapped in plastic police
charged them with murder aggravated
battery and failure to report a child
death last night probably 9:30 went to
bed friends senior and Cunningham
allegedly mislead police four days after
reporting their son missing miss
Cunningham doesn't know what happened to
AJ and had nothing to do with the
disappearance of AJ AJ please come home
we love you very much according to
police reports law enforcement had been
called to the couple's home multiple
times since 2014 due to reports of child
neglect and drug abuse but police could
not confirm either accusation and the
Illinois Department of Child and Family
Services had allowed AJ to stay at AJ's
family it is my hope that you may have
some solace in knowing that AJ is no
longer suffering and
killers have been brought to justice in
a statement Illinois DCFS said it is
committed to conducting a comprehensive
review to understand our shortcomings
Ajay's little brother has already been
placed in another home if the parents
are convicted of the murder charges they
could face life in prison and I just
keep thinking about his little brother
having to grow up and understand what
that yes Ricky thank you